many parents are struggling with how to
talk to their children about yesterday's
school shooting in the shootings before
that before that and before that but
what to do if your kids are anxious
about returning to the classroom we are
going to talk about that right now we
are joined now by jamie howard thank you
so much she's a senior clinical
psychologist from the child mind
institute um we didn't hope to see you
so soon yeah um especially under these
terms but we do appreciate you many
parents think that talking to their
children about a school shooting might
upset their children maybe even
themselves and i can raise my hand on
that one but why do you believe it's
important for parents to have these very
open and honest conversations we want
kids to learn about big traumatic things
from a trusted adult if they learn about
it from other kids on the playground in
homeroom or overhearing it on the radio
in a store then they're going to hear
potentially more sensational bits
they're not going to have accurate
information and it's more likely to
scare them so we want trusted loving
adults to be the ones to deliver this
kind of big scary information to kids
what age do you believe we should start
talking to our kids around school age
right so if you think that your child
might hear it at school or is likely to
hear it from someone else then you want
to get ahead of that and be the one to
tell them so i have a child in preschool
i did not tell him but i did tell my
daughter who's going into kindergarten
because
she just learned the f word from a
friend his older sister so you know we
don't know what what else she might hear
and i want to be the one to tell her
about that it's already hard to discuss
certain things with your children so how
would you on a topic like this
open the conversation
so you know an opener is you know i'm
feeling really sad about a news story
that i saw and i wonder if you've heard
about it so first you can sort of ask
like are you familiar with this have you
been hearing anything and you always
want to start with providing a little
bit of information and let them ask for
more you don't want to jump in with a
lengthy detailed explanation because it
might be more than they need and more
than they want so you can say i heard
some kids got hurt have you heard about
that and then let them say how did they
get hurt or you know what what other
questions they might have and you can
sort of meet them where they're at you
know what i keep thinking jamie that
these kids were second grade third grade
fourth grade which means you're seven
eight nine ten
school is your happy place we all
remember that age we couldn't wait to go
to school to see our teachers to see our
friends right
what do you say to the children
to the parents whose kids are saying i
don't want to go back to school and it
hasn't even happened at their school
and i think too about the horror of what
these other children who survived
the children i can't only imagine that
conversations parents are having with
their children this morning right and
their kids are saying i don't want to go
to school well of course that's a
natural urge right when we think that
we're under threat so the thing to keep
in mind is statistically it still is
unlikely very very unlikely to happen
and it doesn't feel like it though it
doesn't stay it doesn't feel so close to
home yes
and that's that's the way the human mind
works we see something big and scary and
it could affect us and we imagine it
affecting us and and we should take
action and we need to do something to
help these families that have been
through this and at the same time it's
still relatively
unlikely that it's going to happen in
your school and so you want to talk to
your kids about safety measures in place
so that's what i did for example i was
like what did you say it was like well
let's think about how people get into
your school the doors are locked and
they have a system where you have to put
your license in and then they scan it
before they'll unlock the doors
reminding them about reminding them of
like what the grown-ups around them are
doing to help keep them safe they
practice stay put drills in their school
um where the doors are locked and they
stay quiet and i don't think my daughter
even knew what they were for so they
weren't so scary to her
now she has a better understanding that
they're to help keep her safe you know
kids expect grown-ups to fix things and
as we mentioned you know sort of opening
up this bigger bigger question to them
as who is going to fix this how do you
explain that this keeps happening over
and over again
and the problem isn't getting fixed
i think you can have some transparency
you don't want to seem necessarily out
of control irate in front of your kids
because that scares them when you have
big emotions like that but you can say
this makes me really angry it's our job
to protect you and we're not doing that
and so here's what i'm going to do i'm
going to write to local federal
government and say 18 year olds
shouldn't have guns their brains aren't
developed yet they can't buy alcohol and
they can't drive a cup they can't rent a
car why can they have a gun so i'm going
to do that for you and i'm also going to
stay really active in our community to
try to monitor safety for you what i've
learned recently is that my kids are
usually a reflection of how i'm feeling
and because
i play football for so long
i put on this
this face that everything's okay
if i feel like crying i'll do it in my
room
if i feel that i'm stressed i'll make
sure my kids don't see me
what advice do you give to parents
that are walking into their home and
they have the weight of the world on
their shoulders they are emotionally
depleted
and they don't want to
give that to their kids because they
wear like a cologne as they walk around
right yes kids really do vibe off of us
so we want to be mindful of the
intensity of our emotional expression so
it's okay if we look sad it's okay if we
look angry just we want to keep it sort
of a moderate intensity because if it's
too big it feels scary to them
that's helpful thank you so much and
it's scary to me i mean it is children
i'm actually scared myself
about what is happening to us as a
nation as a people it's very scary to me
it's yeah it's very scary and and it
makes a lot of us very angry yep yes we
appreciate you jamie thank you so much